- [Narrator] Although there
are many castles in Germany,
there's none quite like Eltz Castle.
It has been privately owned
by the Eltz family since 1157.
The Eltz Castle was originally constructed
in the 11th century.
However, additions and restorations
have been made over the years.
Unlike most castles, Eltz
Castle isn't easy to spot.
It sits off the main road,
high on a rock within a low valley
and is surrounded by a lush forest.
Many visitors are drawn
to the hiking trails
surrounding the castle grounds.
Thirty-four generations of the Eltz family
have lived among the castle's 120 rooms.
And since today, no one in the
family lives there full time,
the ancestral home is open to the public.
Every year over 300,000 visitors
come to see the castle
and its armory, treasury
and original furnishings that
are over eight centuries old.
Throughout Europe's tumultuous history,
this enchanting castle was
never invaded or destroyed.
Its rich history has earned it a spot
on the 500 Deutsche Mark note,
making it a special sight for those
who get to experience it in person.